now once a coronavirus vaccine is
approved distribution will need to
happen
fast with long-term care facilities
among the first in line
big pharmacy chains like walgreens and
cvs are stepping in to help big time
first on cbs this morning we're joined
by rick gates he is walgreens lead
executive for the covet 19 vaccine
he's also the company's senior vice
president of pharmacy and health care
good morning good to see you mr gates
good morning it's great to be with you
we should also point out you are a
pharmacist by training
so you know what you're talking about
here i googled this morning you might
like to know this rick that a pharmacist
is in the top three of the most trusted
professions in the country
so kudos to you on that but let's start
with walgreens this is what you guys do
you administer vaccines
all of the time but you've never done it
on this scale
so what are you doing how's the process
going to work to make sure that the
long-term
facilities also known as nursing homes
get this done and get it done
effectively what's the plan
yeah and i think what you said upfront
is is what's most important this is what
we do you know i'd say actually pharmacy
has been vaccinating for well over 10
years and if he actually stepped back
we were one of the leads in expanding it
in the h1n1 pandemic and i had the
pleasure of trying to plan that as well
from a walgreens perspective so
you know vaccinations and and getting
out and protecting americans is what
pharmacy has been core at
when you look at it from an uh from the
covet pandemic
obviously we've been working tirelessly
over the last
six to eight months with obviously ows
hhs cdc
and the states to ensure that we have a
very solid plan
for when there is vaccine approved and
then getting it out
into plans with the states to get to
long-term care facilities
so do you have logistical concerns
because as you know rick this is
massive you know
i would say that if you think about
off-site clinics like we're doing with
long-term care facilities we've been
doing that as well for years
we've done about 150 000 off-site
clinics over the last five years
so it's something that's core to what
walgreens does so
we do that consistently i would say
logistically there are nuances to the
coping vaccines so
in particular the pfizer vaccine and the
ultra cold storage we have had to make
some logistical changes but we're very
confident that the freezer storage
uh facilities that we have as well as
dry ice
type solutions in hub locations will
allow us to safely store
the vaccine and then ultimately get it
to the long-term care facilities
for administration so what's it once
it's open to the general population
what's to prevent people from just
storming the stores
how are you going to handle that you
know
obviously there are concerns with
general population but i would say that
you know secretary azar said earlier
today you're going to see consistent
amounts of vaccines that will be out
into the population
and it's going to be something that
we're going to be managing with states
to really prioritize populations ensure
that the right patients are scheduled
and we obviously are
are protecting the patients that have
been prioritized by the states as well
um you know i don't i don't foresee it
being long lines waiting for it but do
we sign up do we sign up is it going to
work in a sign up basis or is it first
come first serve
i'm trying to get people to understand
exactly how the process is going to work
you know a lot of details still being
worked out for phase two a lot of our
focus has been on the long-term care
facilities for phase one
i would say for the general population
the expectation would be that we will
follow state guidelines for prioritized
populations we will work with that to
ensure that we have the right people
signed up
scheduled and with appointments so that
it's easy and seamless for them and
obviously we need to ensure that they
get second dose for those vaccines where
it is uh necessary
rick it's tony de copo your rivals cbs
say they're hiring thousands of
additional workers to help with
vaccination admin and also distribution
are you also hiring workers and then a
second point on that uh cbs is talking
about
potential hero pay they call it for
people who are doing the job in a higher
risk scenario like going into long-term
care
facilities is that something you've
thought about
you know we're looking at all different
ways to ensure that we have the right
staffing and appropriate safety
protocols for our team members and
obviously for
uh who we're protecting in long-term
care facilities so we've run the gamma
to ensure that we've got the right
staffing
if we don't we're going to hire up in
the appropriate areas and ensure that we
have the right pharmacy teams going out
to these facilities to ensure that we've
got
safe and effective vaccination for all
residents of long-term care facilities
as well as obviously for any of the
employees as well
people are still very afraid rick to
take the vaccine you know that we were
making a joke about the lady in britain
who got and then you saw her break
dancing or dancing
i mean i think that's a great ad
campaign but you know people are very
very afraid what are you going to do to
help people with their comfort level
yeah
you know that's a great question and i
would actually look at the the flu
vaccine even this year we've had record
numbers of individuals get the flu
vaccine this year but still
uh well i think it's close to 50 percent
of americans did not get the vaccine so
we're going to have similar challenges
from an education perspective
when it comes to the covet vaccine we've
got to work with cdc we've got to work
with the pharma manufacturers and
understand the science behind it
so that we i think you you call us one
of the top three trusted professions i
think pharmacy can play a huge role
in education and ensuring the public
understands the actual safety
of what this is and how we actually are
putting protocols in place to
ensure that safety going forward as well
yeah people trust the white coats all
right rick gates
thank you very much we appreciate it